one of the things i found really moving
in the book was the way
you paid tribute to the achievements of
your children
was it sam who helped you with a bit of
online trolling
with the virtual world uh within the
whole online thing
so my daughter see my instagram they're
doing my instagram posts
and my son is there to kind of
troubleshoot for me and very early on
and i was
i was my daughter explained to me what
fomo meant
because that was my whole life i was
fearful missing out because i couldn't
catch up with everybody
and uh so i i i she taught me that but
then i got i got in trouble
on twitter somebody who said something
nasty about
parkinson's and i usually let that stuff
just go by me it doesn't happen that
often when it does that
don't really care about it but i just i
wanted to answer this guy in some way
so my son said just do this do smh
and i said what do you mean ask me just
just trust me do smh
so i answered the guy back smh and he
answered me back that's the funniest
thing i've ever read in my life
you're the king of the internet i
apologize for anything i said to you
blah blah blah i said to my son what the
[ __ ] did you say
and he said shaking my head
[Applause]
[Music]